oh hi sir
welcome to the Apple store how can I
help you today hi I'd like one iPad pro
please that's a fine choice sir
yes Apple has really outdone it with
this new iPad pro model sir open take my
money
so I'm guessing you want to talk about
surface as this is the fourth generation
fourth generation of building a tablet
that can replace your laptop and that we
are there s s let me introduce you the
latest surface pen I'm just going to
walk you through the features it has a
tail eraser and comes with an eraser the
Apple pencil doesn't have one now I'm
not going to compare it to any pad I
don't care what size or any tablet
they're not in the same class but
where's your iPad Pro now Apple you guys
sell that thing to fisher-price get that
toy out of here you guys won't talk
about another product
this is surface book hauling me to
laptop Microsoft made a laptop this
product is going back to reinventing
categories take a look at this video one
more time just one more time but this
time swatch a little bit closer what
what
it's a clipboard it's detachable too
constantine come check this out check it
out cry yourself to sleep it's the first
laptop from Microsoft this is surface
book this is the ultimate laptop shut up
and take my money
yeah take that song take it take it all
you're such a nerd you mad bro oh oh
well this isn't happening
Apple is still the best oh don't worry
sir
it'll be okay hold me oh okay great
snuggle on in here huh there you go
you're strong
is it over yet yes yes yes yes cry then
cry taste my Apple you don't have a
choice anymore they're part of the Apple
family now we'll never leave your side
what what what haha alright cut just
wait until next year we'll get you
another you know it yeah
let's rub your head a little bit that'll
make it all day
Oh better yeah you know for $40 extra
you can get a little taste of my Genius
Bar is that including tax oh not a
chance
nightmare how do you like these apples
is that a banana banana hold me
that's alright that's alright okay
Microsoft people have Microsoft penises
yeah I bet you don't have them like
yourself penis mm-hmm that's it that's
the post-credits are there hey guys
dad's here Adam here Barrett and I'm
Konstantin and if you like this video
you can check out some more than we've
done or you can click it right there or
there or somewhere somewhere here
alright thanks for watching yeah see ya